This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Earlier this year, Kurt Coles said a producing episode about trains, only trains, and nothing but trains, featuring strange and amazing rail cars and routes from around the world. But he ran into a little bit of a problem. Fortunately, it was the good kind of problem. I had way too many train stories for a single episode. And not just my ideas, but also ideas sent in by fans. And it was pretty clear from all the tweets and emails that you, beautiful nerds, would be down for a second round of train stories.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今年早些时候，库尔特·科尔斯泰德说要制作一期关于火车的节目，只讲火车，全是火车，介绍世界各地奇特而惊人的轨道车辆和路线。但他遇到了一个小问题。幸运的是，这是一个好问题。关于火车的素材太多了，一期节目根本讲不完。不仅有我的想法，还有粉丝们发来的点子。从所有的推文和邮件中可以清楚地看出，你们这些可爱的书呆子们，肯定会支持第二轮火车故事。
So here it is, train set, track 2, all aboard. Greetings passengers. This story starts not with a train, but with a photo of a train. When I was working on our previous episode about trains, I found this wonderful picture of this cable car in Wellington. And I decided to use it as a lead image on our website when we released that episode. Yes, I remember that one. This is really lovely shot. It's a red finicular climbing up a hill in a city with mountains in the background. You know, the funny thing was, we didn't actually talk about that finicular, did we? No, no, we didn't.
所以，这就是第二轮，火车集，轨道2，请上车。乘客们，大家好。这个故事不是从一列火车开始的，而是从一张火车的照片开始的。当我在制作上一期关于火车的节目时，我发现了这张惠灵顿缆车的精美照片。我决定在发布那期节目时，把它作为我们网站的头图。是的，我记得那张照片。那是一张非常可爱的照片。一辆红色的缆车正沿着城市里的山坡向上爬，背景是群山。你知道，有趣的是，我们实际上并没有谈论那辆缆车，对吧？不，没有，我们没谈。
I was just looking for the ultimate train picture. Plus, I figured it's a finicular, that's something you would enjoy. Yeah, of course. You know, who didn't enjoy it? New Zealander's. They were very polite about it, but it was clear that seeing an image
我当时只是在寻找终极的火车照片。另外，我想既然是缆车，那应该是你会喜欢的。是的，当然。你知道，谁不喜欢呢？新西兰人。他们对此非常有礼貌，但很明显，看到一张照片
had gotten more than a few Wellingtonians excited about their city being featured on the show. So I started chatting with a friend who lives in Wellington, and well, I'll just let her set the seeking. One of the first things you notice when you move to Wellington is these funny little rails going up the hill as you drive along. And you're like, well, what the heck is that? Is that an elevator?
让不少惠灵顿人对他们的城市出现在节目中感到兴奋。于是我开始和一位住在惠灵顿的朋友聊天，好吧，我还是让她来介绍背景吧。当你搬到惠灵顿，开车经过时，首先注意到的就是这些沿着山坡向上延伸的有趣小轨道。你会想，这到底是什么鬼？那是电梯吗？
That's my friend and de facto New Zealand correspondent, Pepper. I'm Pepper Raccoon, and I'm an artist from Wellington, New Zealand. Her name is Pepper Raccoon. That is outstanding. I can see why you guys hit it off. And those rails that she's talking about, they're not just for that one main cable car. There are a bunch of smaller private trains around the city too. I think, honestly, Wellington is the best place to come for a tour of the best
那是我的朋友，也是我们事实上的新西兰通讯员，佩珀。我是佩珀·浣熊，我是来自新西兰惠灵顿的一名艺术家。她的名字叫佩珀·浣熊。这太出色了。我明白为什么你们俩能合得来了。她提到的那些轨道，不仅仅是为那一条主要的缆车准备的。城市周围还有很多较小的私人火车。我认为，老实说，惠灵顿是参观最好的
finiculars. It's a, yeah, it's a smorgasbord, really. There's so many different ones, and they all look completely different. And she explained to me that there are actually hundreds of local finiculars in Wellington. They range from like a fiberglass bucket on a single rail to like effectively a beautiful little room elevator that mimics the style of your home on a dual rail that gives it a much smoother and stable ride. So it's like, yeah, you can go real fancy. So Wellington is now becoming like the first city of my heart because it has tons of finiculars, which as we all know,
缆车的地方。这真的是一个大杂烩。有太多不同的缆车了，而且它们看起来完全不同。她向我解释说，惠灵顿实际上有数百个当地的缆车。它们从单轨上的玻璃纤维桶，到实际上模仿你家风格、在双轨上运行、乘坐起来更平稳稳定的漂亮小房间电梯，应有尽有。所以，是的，你可以搞得很高级。所以惠灵顿现在成了我心中的第一城市，因为它有大量的缆车，正如我们所知，
are the greatest form of transportation. Oh, yes. But the question still remains, why are there so many vernacular in Wellington? Right, and it's not so much that the city itself as a public entity needs them, it's that all of these homeowners do, because Wellington is the small coastal city
它们是最好的交通工具。哦，是的。但问题仍然存在，为什么惠灵顿有这么多缆车？对，这并不是因为城市作为一个公共实体需要它们，而是因为所有的房主都需要，因为惠灵顿是一个小的沿海城市，
and it's crammed in between the water and all of these craggy hills. In terms of the topography, it's just a nightmare of like crumbling cliffs. So it makes sense that we ran out of space and so has us kind of ended up on cliffs and on very steep hills. Yeah, it's good. It's also like an insane place though because of the topography. So a lot of things don't make sense here. Or rather they make sense here, but sound weird to everybody else.
它被挤在水域和所有这些崎岖的山丘之间。就地形而言，这简直是一场噩梦，到处都是崩塌的悬崖。所以我们空间不足，最终只能住在悬崖和非常陡峭的山坡上，这也就说得通了。是的，这很好。但因为地形的原因，这里也是一个疯狂的地方。所以很多事情在这里说不通。或者说，它们在这里说得通，但在其他人听起来很奇怪。
And so Wellington is actually one of the most densely populated cities in New Zealand because there's so little flatland to build on, and people have decided to move up and out of the densely peck city and live on these steep slopes, which otherwise might not get built on. And this approach has upsides and it has downsides. So those homes on the coast have incredible views, but unfortunately moving into that means you have to hire a helicopter. So, having forbid you buy a new sofa. Like, I couldn't imagine buying new furniture after having moved in and being like, well, I guess we have to call the helicopter again, like that sucks. But because most people, of course, can't hire a helicopter, every time they want to go to the supermarket. And the only way to get up to some of those houses
因此，惠灵顿实际上是新西兰人口最稠密的城市之一，因为可供建造的平地太少了，人们决定搬出人口稠密的城市，住到这些陡峭的山坡上，否则这些地方可能根本不会被开发。这种方法有利有弊。海岸上的那些房子视野极佳，但不幸的是，搬进去意味着你必须雇一架直升机。所以，天哪，如果你买了新沙发。就像，我无法想象搬进去后买了新家具，然后说，好吧，我想我们又得叫直升机了，那太糟糕了。但因为大多数人当然不能每次去超市都雇直升机。去那些房子唯一的办法
was a set of stairs if you're lucky, and for some houses it's literally just the finicular. So you can get stuck there. Your finicular can break down, and you can just not be able to go anywhere. And they do. Yeah, and they do break down. And they can be dangerous.
如果幸运的话是一组楼梯，而对于一些房子来说，它实际上就是缆车。所以你可能会被困在那里。你的缆车可能会坏掉，你就哪儿也去不了了。它们确实会坏。是的，它们确实会坏。而且它们可能很危险。
Someone did die due to a finicular-related incident before there was regulations around them. And so the government had to institute a warrant of fitness on finiculars, but it's really expensive. When the maintenance costs are so expensive and you have to keep the piles, you know, stable and higher inspectors and all that stuff. And so
在有相关法规之前，确实有人因为缆车相关的事故而死亡。所以政府不得不对缆车实行适航证制度，但这非常昂贵。当维护成本如此昂贵，你必须保持桩基稳定，聘请检查员等等。所以
that cost becomes a pretty big deal because these trains aren't being run by the city, they're owned, operated, and maintained by individuals or small groups of homeowners. Some people have teamed up, so there'll be three or four houses on the same vernacular track, and so you just share it. And that seems really sensible.
这笔费用就成了一个大问题，因为这些火车不是由城市运营的，它们是由个人或一小群房主拥有、运营和维护的。有些人组成了团队，所以会有三四户人家共用同一条缆车轨道，这样你们就分摊了费用。这看起来真的很明智。
And so a lot of people don't get fancy with their verniculars either. They just need something to get them tuned from home safely, something they can afford. But even the safety part is a little bit optional. And as the islanders also have this really dangerous and kind of entertaining, seems whimsical, but also kind of terrible philosophy called, she'll be right, which is just build something. Don't worry too much about it. She'll be right, which is just build something. Don't worry too much about it. She'll be right. It's fine. And unfortunately, I think a lot of the funiculars that existed before the warn of fitness
所以很多人在缆车上也不会搞得太花哨。他们只需要一种能安全地往返家中的工具，一种他们负担得起的工具。但即使是安全部分也有点可选。而且岛民们还有一种非常危险、有点娱乐性、看起来异想天开，但也有些糟糕的哲学，叫“没问题”（she'll be right），意思就是随便造点什么。别太担心。没问题，随便造点什么。别太担心。没问题。挺好的。不幸的是，我认为在适航证制度出现之前存在的许多缆车
might have been on that kind of spectrum. Because it's all funiculars and games until someone gets hurt. But despite them being janky and unpredictable, she absolutely wants to hide on a private vernacular. Okay, I've been on the cable car. I have never been on a personal vernacular. And the one person that I talked to that was willing to let me ride on their vernacular, their vernacular was broken. Broke in.
可能都属于那种范畴。因为在有人受伤之前，一切都是缆车游戏。但尽管它们破旧且不可预测，她绝对想坐一次私人缆车。好吧，我坐过缆车。我从来没坐过私人缆车。我交谈过的唯一一个愿意让我坐他们缆车的人，他们的缆车坏了。坏了。
Which I have been told is very common. Hahaha. Next stop will be Goet Canyon, California. Please be advised that the track beyond this point is abandoned. Goet Canyon is situated in a beautiful stretch of desert east of San Diego, California. And it's a great place to ride the rails. Oh, big rock, big rock. Oh, I'm sick. Oh, yeah.
据我所知，这很常见。哈哈。下一站是加利福尼亚州的戈特峡谷。请注意，此点之后的轨道已被废弃。戈特峡谷位于加利福尼亚州圣地亚哥以东的一片美丽的沙漠中。这是一个骑行轨道的好地方。哦，大石头，大石头。哦，我晕了。哦，是的。
So now we got to move some shit all the way here. Okay, so what am I looking at here? Basically, like a really low-tech go kart that runs on rails instead of roads. So it's this bare bones plywood platform with four wheels attached and a couple of bucket seats and a motor and beyond that, just a cooler strap between them for beers
所以现在我们得把东西搬到这儿来。好吧，我在这儿看到了什么？基本上，就像一个在轨道上而不是在路上运行的低科技卡丁车。所以它是一个简陋的胶合板平台，装有四个轮子，还有几个桶形座椅和一个发动机，除此之外，中间还绑着一个装啤酒的冷却器
and sandwiches and whatnot. And in this particular video, you've got two brothers who are out there, one who built the thing and one who's recording their adventure, and they're just taking to these abandoned rails. So clearly this is an abandoned set of tracks. So where are they going? They're heading up to see the goat canyon Tressel Bridge, which was built nearly a hundred years ago, and it's the largest wood Tressel Bridge in the world. Largest, per wood, Tressel.
和三明治之类的东西。在这个特定的视频中，有两个兄弟在那里，一个造了这个东西，另一个在记录他们的冒险，他们只是在这些废弃的轨道上行驶。所以很明显这是一组废弃的轨道。那么他们要去哪儿？他们正前往观看戈特峡谷栈桥，它建于近一百年前，是世界上最长的木制栈桥。最长的，木制，栈桥。
So it's this massive and daunting structure that's around 750 feet long and 200 feet high. But like if you're on rails and you're going 20 miles an hour and it's an abandoned track and maybe some other daredevil is also going 20 miles an hour, hopefully in the same direction, maybe not in the same direction. I mean, like what happens? Right. So the good thing is these cards don't weigh a lot, so they don't have a ton of mass, which means they can stop relatively quickly if you see an obstacle.
所以这是一个巨大而令人生畏的结构，大约750英尺长，200英尺高。但如果你在轨道上，以每小时20英里的速度行驶，这是一条废弃的轨道，也许还有其他敢死队也在以每小时20英里的速度行驶，希望是同一个方向，也许不是同一个方向。我的意思是，会发生什么？对。所以好消息是这些车重量不大，所以它们没有太大的质量，这意味着如果你看到障碍物，它们可以相对较快地停下来。
Plus, people who regularly ride these stretches, they know more or less what to expect. People like Gabe Emerson, a tinker from Alaska, who has built a few rail cards over the years. In this video, I'm going to try to make a rail road speeder or homemade rail cart. Now I've had a couple of these in the past. If you've seen my prior videos, you may have seen the horrible antique metal one. And you've probably seen my horrible plastic one that kept derailing constantly. My hope here is to make one that actually stays on the track,
另外，经常在这些路段骑行的人，他们或多或少知道会发生什么。像加布·埃默森这样的人，来自阿拉斯加的修补匠，多年来他制造了几辆轨道车。在这个视频中，我将尝试制造一辆铁路轨道车或自制轨道车。我过去有过几辆。如果你看过我之前的视频，你可能见过那辆可怕的古董金属车。你可能也见过我那辆不断脱轨的可怕塑料车。我在这里的希望是制造一辆真正能留在轨道上的车，
and that I can take out to some abandoned railroads for a bit of fun. And true to the title of his video channel, Save It For Parts, Gabe is using pieces he's recycling from these previous builds, like a pedal-powered rail bike that he built and a speeder that was kind of like this one, but this time he added a new motor and a gas pedal. And of course, he doesn't need a steering wheel
我可以把它带到一些废弃的铁路上玩一玩。正如他的视频频道名称“留着零件”（Save It For Parts）所言，加布正在使用他从之前的作品中回收的零件，比如他制造的一辆脚踏轨道自行车，还有一辆类似于这辆的轨道车，但这次他增加了一个新发动机和一个油门踏板。当然，他不需要方向盘
because it's on train tracks with no turns. And in the end this creation worked more or less. Like chain keeps jumping off. I need like a tensioner or something on here. Actually I lost a nut for my finally, finally engineered gearing system. So that's why the chain keeps popping off. Oh geez, here come the parking. So these referring to here are these park cops who happen to be passing by and apparently driving a little weird DIY vehicle at slow speeds down an abandoned set of railroad tracks isn't something they're used to ticketing.
因为它在没有转弯的火车轨道上。最后，这个作品或多或少成功了。链条一直在跳脱。我需要一个张紧器之类的东西。实际上，我弄丢了我那精心设计的传动系统的一个螺母。这就是为什么链条一直在掉。哦，天哪，公园警察来了。所以这里提到的这些人是碰巧经过的公园警察，显然，以低速在废弃的铁路上驾驶一辆奇怪的DIY车辆并不是他们习惯开罚单的事情。
In any case, after that game reflected on his work and called it a day. This thing may not be fast, but at least it's ugly. Are you allowed to do that? Oh, no, no, definitely not. In general, yeah, no. But there are some legal DIY rail riding options for people who want to, you know, stay above board or just don't want to build their own carts. Okay, so, so like what?
无论如何，在那之后，加布反思了他的工作，并结束了一天的工作。这东西可能不快，但至少它很丑。你被允许这样做吗？哦，不，不，绝对不行。总的来说，是的，不行。但对于那些想要，你知道，保持合法或者只是不想自己制造车辆的人来说，有一些合法的DIY轨道骑行选择。好吧，那么，像什么？
Well, there's this place up in Northern California, for example, near Fort Bragg called railbikes. And they rent out four-wheeled, two-seat vehicles that use a combination of electricity and pedal power. For a long time, there was this 40-mile active rail line that ran between Fort Bragg and Willitz. But then about a decade ago, this key tunnel along the route collapsed and basically cut the line into. So people on both sides decided to spend up these shorter rail options like this to make the best of a bad situation. Huh. Well, it makes sense.
嗯，北加州有一个地方，比如布拉格堡附近，叫“轨道自行车”（railbikes）。他们出租四轮双座车辆，使用电力和脚踏动力的组合。很长一段时间里，布拉格堡和威利茨之间有一条40英里的活跃铁路线。但大约十年前，沿线的一条关键隧道坍塌了，基本上把线路切成了两段。所以两边的人决定建立这些较短的轨道选择，比如这个，以在糟糕的情况下做到最好。嗯。好吧，这说得通。
I mean, they're there, why not use them if they can't be used by trains. Let's use them for some else. Right. So where the collapse happened, it's all rubble covered useless train tracks. But on either side of that fairly narrow crisis point, our tracks that were actively maintained until quite recently, making for a safer ride. And there's all this existing rail infrastructure
我的意思是，它们就在那里，如果火车不能用，为什么不利用它们呢。让我们把它们用于其他用途。对。所以坍塌发生的地方，到处都是碎石覆盖的无用火车轨道。但在那个相当狭窄的危机点的两侧，是直到最近才被积极维护的轨道，这使得骑行更安全。而且所有这些现有的铁路基础设施
already in place, stuff like crossing gates and bells and signals for where the rails intersect the roads. And that infrastructure is now used to stop traffic so rail bikes can cross. It's kind of funny when you go through the railroad crossings and all the gates come down and these rail bikes go past with us waving at the people in the cars. That sounds amazing. Yeah and of course they vary in terms of legality, some being a little less illegal than others, but honestly I would write any of them. Attention passengers! For those interested in taking home a train of their own, there are model trains in our onboard gift shop. New Young is best known for his music, but he also has a lesser known passion, model
都已经到位了，比如交叉路口的闸门、铃铛和信号灯，用于轨道与道路交叉的地方。而这些基础设施现在被用来停止交通，以便轨道自行车可以通过。当你穿过铁路交叉口，所有的闸门都降下来，这些轨道自行车经过，我们向车里的人挥手，这很有趣。这听起来太棒了。是的，当然，它们的合法性各不相同，有些比其他的稍微不那么非法，但老实说，我会骑任何一种。乘客们请注意！对于那些有兴趣带一列火车回家的人，我们的机上礼品店有模型火车。尼尔·杨以他的音乐而闻名，但他还有一个鲜为人知的爱好，模型
train sets. He got his first one at age five and throughout his years touring as a world famous musician, he built up a collection of vintage, Lionel model train sets. Neil's two sons, Zeke and Ben, were both born with cerebral palsy. In Ben's case, it rendered him quadriplegic and nonverbal. Neil's then wife Peggy, struggling to find good schools for children with disabilities, founded the Bridge School in 1986, and Neal found a unique way to engage with Ben through trains. When I started building the railroad, I built it so that my son and I could have something to do together.
火车套装。他在五岁时得到了第一套，在他作为世界著名音乐家巡演的多年里，他建立了一个复古的莱昂内尔模型火车套装收藏。尼尔的两个儿子，泽克和本，都患有脑瘫。在本的案例中，这使他四肢瘫痪且无法说话。尼尔当时的妻子佩吉，在为残疾儿童寻找好学校时遇到了困难，于1986年创办了桥梁学校，尼尔发现了一种通过火车与本互动的独特方式。当我开始建造铁路时，我建造它是为了让我和我的儿子能一起做点什么。
Neal extensively modified his vintage trains, adapting the controls to suit band's abilities. I developed a model train control system for Lionel and the sound systems, because I basically made this for my kid, so he could do it with his little switch. Here's some kind of a mechanical electronic, in addition to being musically very nerdy, I think. He holds seven patents for his train innovations, including remote control and more realistic
尼尔广泛地改装了他的复古火车，调整了控制装置以适应本的能力。我为莱昂内尔和音响系统开发了一个模型火车控制系统，因为我基本上是为我的孩子做的，这样他就可以用他的小开关来操作。这是一种机械电子设备，除了在音乐上非常书呆子气之外，我想。他拥有七项火车创新专利，包括远程控制和更逼真的
sounds. He worked closely with Lionel in the early 1990s, and they incorporated his designs into the train master command control. Around the same time, Lionel faced bankruptcy, and Neil led a group of investors to bail them out. Ben frequently accompanies his dad on tour, and these days, with the help of modern speech communication devices, runs a successful organic egg farm. In recent years, Neil has begun to sell off his vast model chain collection.
声音。他在20世纪90年代初与莱昂内尔密切合作，他们将他的设计整合到了火车大师指挥控制系统中。大约在同一时间，莱昂内尔面临破产，尼尔带领一群投资者救助了他们。本经常陪同他的父亲巡演，如今，在现代语音通信设备的帮助下，他经营着一个成功的有机鸡蛋农场。近年来，尼尔开始出售他庞大的模型火车收藏。
In part, he wants others to find joy and connection through these vintage sets. But he's also doing it for a good cause. He's donating the proceeds to the Bridge School to help other kids like Ben. This train will never run me down But only take me where I'm bound. It's part of me and part of you. I'll always be a part of you.
在某种程度上，他希望其他人能通过这些复古套装找到快乐和联系。但他这样做也是为了一个好的事业。他将收益捐赠给桥梁学校，以帮助其他像本一样的孩子。这列火车永远不会撞倒我，只会带我去我要去的地方。它是我的一部分，也是你的一部分。我将永远是你的一部分。
Our next stop will be Mecca, Saudi Arabia. Please note, this route is only operational until the end of the week. So there's this train line that for one week a year has the highest reported capacity of any metro system in the entire world. But there's a caveat. It only operates for one week a year. Okay, I'm hooked. So why build a train that runs only one week a year. The network is based in Mecca, and the reason it only operates for this short annual period is that it's designed for a single purpose, moving Muslims around the region during the Hage. Okay, that makes sense. So pilgrims are traveling to Mecca.
我们的下一站将是沙特阿拉伯的麦加。请注意，此路线仅在本周末前运营。所以有一条火车线路，一年中有一周的载客量是全世界所有地铁系统中最高的。但有一个警告。它一年只运营一周。好吧，我被吸引了。那么为什么要建造一列一年只运行一周的火车呢？该网络位于麦加，它只在这一年一度的短时间内运营的原因是，它是为了一个单一的目的而设计的，即在朝觐期间运送穆斯林在区域内移动。好吧，这说得通。所以朝圣者正在前往麦加。
They need to get between various holy sites, and it's only a short time of the year. With substantial increases in the number of pilgrims and vehicles carrying them in the holy sites, the road network has become unable to accommodate pedestrians and vehicles simultaneously. So the whole region is notoriously crowded during Holy Week and people flood in during the hodge because one of the five pillars of Islam is visiting Mecca at least once in your lifetime, at least for those who are able and during this one narrow window of time each year. So I know millions of people make the pilgrimage each year and I've read that things can get pretty crowded and dangerous even
他们需要在各个圣地之间穿梭，而且一年中只有很短的时间。随着朝圣者人数和运送他们的车辆在圣地的大幅增加，道路网络已经无法同时容纳行人和车辆。所以整个地区在圣周期间以拥挤著称，人们在朝觐期间涌入，因为伊斯兰教的五功之一是至少一生中访问一次麦加，至少对于那些有能力的人来说，而且是在每年这一狭窄的时间窗口内。所以我知道每年有数百万人进行朝圣，我读到过事情可能会变得非常拥挤和危险，甚至
deadly because when you have that many people it can turn into a stampede. Yes, absolutely. The crowding has led to some really tragic deaths in the past, but there are other health risks too. The region gets super hot during a hodge so spending a lot of time outside traveling between sites can be risky. Physical safety is definitely part of what drove this project. The government of the Castudian of the two Hauli mosques decided to build a railway in the southern section of the Holy Sites. The southern line, Gupt, Al-Masherar al-Mukadde-Sahmithra
致命，因为当你拥有那么多人时，它可能会变成踩踏事件。是的，绝对是。拥挤在过去导致了一些非常悲惨的死亡，但也有其他健康风险。该地区在朝觐期间变得非常热，所以在圣地之间旅行时花很多时间在外面可能会有风险。身体安全绝对是推动这个项目的部分原因。两圣地监护人政府决定在圣地南部区域建造一条铁路。南部线路，古普特，阿尔-马沙尔·阿尔-穆卡达萨米特拉
will be the most effective solution to transport the largest possible number of pilgrims in the shortest possible time. So as you can imagine back in the day, these pilgrims are traveling by camel or on foot, and then when these roads came along, as any urbanist knows, they ironically led to more congestion, not less, especially with the rise of personal motor vehicles. So in 2009, they started building this rail line, and the project employed thousands of engineers and even more construction workers who in total had to move nearly 200 million
将是在最短时间内运送尽可能多朝圣者的最有效解决方案。所以你可以想象，在过去，这些朝圣者是骑骆驼或步行旅行的，然后当这些道路出现时，正如任何城市规划者所知，它们讽刺地导致了更多的拥堵，而不是更少，特别是随着个人机动车辆的兴起。所以2009年，他们开始建造这条铁路线，该项目雇佣了数千名工程师和更多的建筑工人，他们总共不得不移动近2亿
cubic meters of earth. And despite that, the whole thing was completed in just two years, which is incredibly fast if you think about the scope. And then in 2011, it carried nearly four million pilgrims around between these holy sites. Wow. I mean, that is hard to imagine for my people being moved in a way. Right. Yeah. And if you break it down even further, it can carry 70,000 people per hour, which I also have a hard time imagining, because it has trains leading every few minutes. And in terms of what this offset's in terms of other traffic, they calculated that this train system replaces the need for over 50,000 surface
立方米的土方。尽管如此，整个工程仅在两年内就完成了，如果你考虑到规模，这非常快。然后在2011年，它在这些圣地之间运送了近四百万朝圣者。哇。我的意思是，这对于我的人民以某种方式移动来说很难想象。对。是的。如果你进一步细分，它每小时可以运送70,000人，我也很难想象，因为它每隔几分钟就有火车出发。就这在其他交通方面抵消了什么而言，他们计算出这个火车系统取代了超过50,000辆地面
buses, which of course helps reduce that congestion. But why, you know, if they put all this effort into it, why not just keep it open year round just because? You know, I wasn't able to find a definitive official answer for that. My somewhat educated best guess is that it just isn't cost efficient to operate it all the time. And the route isn't really optimized for commuters or other everyday uses. So it really only makes sense during the Hodge. And the Hodge, meanwhile, brings in so much money. It has almost certainly already offset the billions of dollars
巴士的需求，这当然有助于减少拥堵。但为什么，你知道，如果他们投入了所有这些努力，为什么不只是全年开放呢？你知道，我没能找到一个明确的官方答案。我受过某种教育的最佳猜测是，全天候运营它在成本上并不划算。而且这条路线并没有真正为通勤者或其他日常用途进行优化。所以它真的只在朝觐期间才有意义。与此同时，朝觐带来了如此多的金钱。它几乎肯定已经抵消了数十亿美元
that the project costs. Yeah. Just to put that in perspective. So this one doesn't run regularly. But is there one optimized for commuting? Like, is there an everyday metro system in the area? Well, not yet, but they do have another network in the works
该项目的成本。是的。只是为了把那个放在视角中。所以这个不定期运行。但有没有为通勤优化的？比如，该地区有没有日常地铁系统？嗯，还没有，但他们确实有另一个正在筹备中的网络
that's supposed to serve the region more regularly and broadly, which as I understand it won't even link up to this one. It'll just be a completely separate system, and that will be for more everyday use, but this existing line is just going to continue being a once a year affair. Attention passengers. Do not be alarmed as this train is about to take to the sky for each 88 miles per hour and take us back to ancient Rome. Enjoy the ride! There's some old infrastructure lore about the reason why American rails have such
应该更定期、更广泛地服务于该地区，据我了解，它甚至不会与这条线路连接。它将是一个完全独立的系统，那将用于更多的日常使用，但这条现有的线路将继续是一年一次的事情。乘客们请注意。不要惊慌，因为这列火车即将飞向天空，以每小时88英里的速度带我们回到古罗马。享受旅程吧！关于美国铁路为何有如此
specific spacing. The persistent story is that American rail gauges, as in the distance between the metal rails, can be directly traced all the way back to the wheel spacing of ancient imperial Roman chariots. And the logic goes something like this. American rails are spaced four feet eight and a half inches apart, and that seemingly odd number comes from English spacing standards, and those standards in turn were based on wagon construction dimensions, and those had to be standardized so wagons could ride in existing routes, and those routes were initially formed by the Roman Empire and reinforced by other vehicles
特定间距，有一些古老的基建传说。一个持续存在的说法是，美国铁路轨距，即金属轨道之间的距离，可以直接追溯到古代帝国罗马战车的轮距。逻辑是这样的。美国铁路轨距为4英尺8.5英寸，这个看似奇怪的数字来自英国的间距标准，而这些标准反过来又是基于马车结构的尺寸，这些尺寸必须标准化，以便马车可以在现有的路线上行驶，而这些路线最初是由罗马帝国形成的，并自那以后被其他车辆
ever since. Now there is some truth to this train of thought, but the legend itself, which has persisted for over a century, is mostly fanciful. For one thing, ancient Roman roads were built more for foot traffic than for chariots. Plus, current gauges were far from inevitable. For a long time, there was no standard gauge in the United States and a variety were used.
加强。现在这种思维方式确实有一些道理，但这个已经存在了一个多世纪的传说，大多是异想天开的。首先，古代罗马道路的建造更多是为了步行交通而不是战车。另外，当前的轨距远非不可避免。很长一段时间里，美国没有标准轨距，使用了多种轨距。
Ultimately, the relative similarity between modern rail line gauges and ancient rutways are tied more to design than history. Times may have changed, but the physical constraints of vehicles have remained relatively consistent. Axles need to span far enough to support the structure above them, but they can't be too wide or they might snap. So modern gauges aren't really a product of Imperial Rome. History rarely lets us trace such a direct line across such a long period of time. Still,
最终，现代铁路线轨距与古代车辙之间的相对相似性更多地与设计有关，而不是历史。时代可能变了，但车辆的物理限制保持了相对一致。车轴需要跨度足够大以支撑其上方的结构，但它们不能太宽，否则它们可能会断裂。所以现代轨距并不是罗马帝国的产物。历史很少让我们在如此长的时间跨度内追踪到这样一条直接的线索。尽管如此，
it's also not entirely coincidental that rail spacing tends to fall into that certain range because the overall needs and limitations of ancient chariots and medieval wagons and contemporary railroads are broadly more similar than they are different. Next stop, Anchorage, Alaska. If you wish to disembark before we arrive, please alert the conductor for a manual stop. Way up in Alaska, there's this one particular train that works differently from probably any train you've ever taken. It operates on what's known as a flag stop basis.
铁路间距往往落入那个特定范围也不是完全巧合，因为古代战车、中世纪马车和当代铁路的总体需求和限制在很大程度上是相似的，而不是不同的。下一站，阿拉斯加州安克雷奇。如果您希望在我们到达之前下车，请提醒列车员进行手动停车。在阿拉斯加，有一列特别的火车，它的工作方式可能与你乘坐过的任何火车都不同。它以所谓的“旗帜停车”（flag stop）方式运营。
Okay, trains and flags. All right. Onward. Okay, so what does it mean for a rail line to operate on a flag stop basis? What a flag stop train is is basically a train that stops on demand. When somebody needs to get off or get on. And there are some train routes that use a form of higher tech Flagstop service. Like they only slow down at a station if somebody is booked to take it from there in advance, right?
好吧，火车和旗帜。好的。继续。好吧，那么铁路以旗帜停车方式运营意味着什么？旗帜停车火车基本上是一列按需停车的火车。当有人需要下车或上车时。有些火车路线使用某种更高科技的旗帜停车服务。比如，如果有人提前预订了从那里出发，它们才会在车站减速，对吧？
Or in some parts of the world there are these Flagstop fairies where you have to flick a light switch on and to get a boat's attention. But this kind of classic low tech flagstop train where you literally wave a flag is very uncommon. And this route in Alaska is one of the last of its kind in North America. So how does the actual flagging down work? Like do people just stand alongside the tracks like in the dead of winter in Alaska and just wave a white cloth around or maybe what, you know, or scarf or whatever they have on them?
或者在世界某些地方，有这些旗帜停车渡轮，你必须拨动灯开关来引起船的注意。但这种经典的低科技旗帜停车火车，你字面上挥舞一面旗帜，非常罕见。而阿拉斯加的这条路线是北美最后一条此类路线之一。那么实际的挥旗停车是如何工作的呢？人们是否只是像在阿拉斯加的严冬里那样站在轨道旁边，挥舞一块白布，或者也许是什么，你知道，或者围巾，或者他们身上有的任何东西？
Yeah, basically yes. And the train operators are watching for those signals and stopping when they see them. Huh. So it's a little bit more like a bus, but even buses have bus stops. But what I don't get is, you know, the whole thing that makes a train great is that it efficiently
是的，基本上是的。火车运营商会留意这些信号，并在看到它们时停车。嗯。所以它有点像公共汽车，但即使是公共汽车也有公交车站。但我没搞懂的是，你知道，让火车变得伟大的全部原因在于它高效地
moves on rails and has inertia. And so how can you stop it to do these pickups when the pickups are done, kind of spontaneously? Right. I mean, these things have a ton of mass. But along this particular stretch, the trains are short. They only have two locomotives, two passenger cars, and one baggage car. So they're small enough that they can start and stop
在轨道上移动并具有惯性。所以当接送是那种自发的时候，你怎么能停下来做这些接送呢？对。我的意思是，这些东西有很大的质量。但沿着这一特定路段，火车很短。它们只有两台机车、两节客车和一节行李车。所以它们足够小，可以启动和停止
a lot faster than a normal, you know, full-length locomotive, and still achieve a maximum speed of close to 60 miles an hour. Wow. So if the trains are going up to 60 miles an hour, that means that it's a pretty rural area. So if that's the case, like, who are they stopping for?
比正常的，你知道，全长机车快得多，并且仍然能达到接近每小时60英里的最高速度。哇。所以如果火车时速达到60英里，这意味着它是一个相当偏远的地区。所以如果是这样的话，他们是在为谁停车？
Yeah, well, a lot of them are just visitors who are heading out to hike or fish and remote areas for maybe even a couple of weeks at time, or they're traveling to their seasonal cabins. But the real way also provides a vital service for those brave, brave souls who live way out here in rural Alaska along this stretch. It's been really interesting to see how this railroad provides a lifeline for the 40 or so people who live a lot here. Just hanging out of flag if you wanted to train to stop and they stop and they pick you up or they drop you off wherever you ask the conductor to stop. So some folks use the train to get to and from their homes in the region and they also need
是的，嗯，他们中的许多人只是前往偏远地区徒步旅行或钓鱼的游客，甚至可能一次待上几周，或者他们正在前往他们的季节性小屋。但这条铁路也为那些生活在阿拉斯加偏远地区、沿着这一路段的勇敢的灵魂提供了至关重要的服务。看到这条铁路如何为生活在这里的40人左右提供生命线，真的很有趣。只要挂上一面旗帜，如果你想让火车停下来，他们就会停下来，接你上车，或者把你送到你要求列车员停车的任何地方。所以有些人使用火车往返于该地区的家中，他们也需要
this train to get supply drops. But probably my favorite service they offer is news delivery, which doesn't actually require them to stop at all. Basically there's this real worker who stands there and tosses out print newspapers for area residents from the moving train. They can even get their daily news, courtesy of Harry Ross.
这列火车来获取物资补给。但我最喜欢的服务可能是新闻投递，这实际上根本不需要他们停车。基本上，有一名铁路工人站在那里，从移动的火车上为当地居民扔下印刷报纸。他们甚至可以得到他们的每日新闻，由哈里·罗斯提供。
The people will come out, they'll send their dog out to come and pick up that newspaper and the dog will bring it back to the get. to come and pick up that newspaper and the dog will bring it back to the cat. We have more trains, more Kirk-Colestead and even more Alaska after this. Next stop, Wales, Alaska. This will be our final stop of the day, as the proposed tunnel that would take us to Russia has yet to be constructed. So Kurt, we're still in Alaska?
人们会出来，他们会派他们的狗去取那份报纸，狗会把它带回猫那里。我们还有更多的火车，更多的库尔特·科尔斯泰德，甚至在之后还有更多的阿拉斯加。下一站，阿拉斯加州威尔士。这将是我们今天的最后一站，因为通往俄罗斯的拟议隧道尚未建成。所以库尔特，我们还在阿拉斯加吗？
Oh yes, absolutely. We're still in Alaska. I mean, it's a really, really big state. It's a huge state, and things are pretty spread out, which makes sense that there would be trains between them. But in this case, it's not a real train, or at least not yet. For over a century, there have been various proposals to connect Eastern Russia and Alaska across the Bering Street, a project that would have to span a bit over 50 miles and would
哦，是的，绝对是。我们还在阿拉斯加。我的意思是，这是一个非常非常大的州。这是一个巨大的州，事情分布得很广，这也就说得通为什么它们之间会有火车。但在这种情况下，它不是一列真正的火车，或者至少现在还不是。一个多世纪以来，有各种各样的提议连接俄罗斯东部和阿拉斯加，跨越白令海峡，这是一个必须跨越50多英里，并且会
tie North America to Asia in this unprecedented way. Of course, in the current political climate, it's probably more of a pipe dream, but it would be a world-changing feat of engineering. Such a tunnel would have major benefits. First of all, it would physically link North and South America to the old world. You could ride by train from San Francisco to Beijing in a day and a half and travel by land all the way from Cape Town to Miami. A tunnel would provide a safer, cheaper and faster way to transport freight between Asia
以这种前所未有的方式将北美与亚洲联系起来的项目。当然，在当前的政治气候下，这可能更多是一个白日梦，但这将是一个改变世界的工程壮举。这样的隧道将有重大的好处。首先，它将在物理上将北美和南美与旧世界联系起来。你可以乘火车在一天半内从旧金山到达北京，并一路陆路从开普敦旅行到迈阿密。隧道将提供一种更安全、更便宜、更快捷的方式来运输亚洲之间的货物
and North America. Of course, right now, Russia is the aggressor in a needless and horrible war, but putting geopolitics aside at 50 plus miles, this sounds like a massive undertaking. I can imagine some pretty massive economic benefits for international trade, you know, if things were to work out diplomatically. But are these just pying this guy ideas or are people like really taking this seriously. Well, definitely some people have, including some pretty serious folks who've pitched plans for over a century. For example, you have Joseph Strauss who went on to design something like 400 bridges
和北美。当然，现在，俄罗斯是一场毫无意义且可怕的战争中的侵略者，但撇开地缘政治不谈，在50多英里处，这听起来像是一项巨大的工程。我可以想象国际贸易的一些非常巨大的经济利益，你知道，如果事情能在外交上解决的话。但这些只是空想，还是人们真的在认真对待？嗯，绝对有些人有，包括一些非常严肃的人，他们已经推销计划一个多世纪了。例如，你有约瑟夫·施特劳斯，他后来设计了大约400座桥梁
and was the project engineer for the Golden Gate Bridge. And he did his undergrad thesis on a bearing street bridge. Then in 1905, a more fully fleshed out plan was all but approved, but got axed at the last minute. I mean, if they could build something as beautiful as the golden gate bridge, but 50 miles long, that would be pretty stunning. I mean, what was the thing that killed the project back in 1905? Well, the timing as it turned out was terrible. The Russian revolution was kicking off. So, you know, you know, Zara Nicholas II had bigger fish to
并且是金门大桥的项目工程师。他做了关于白令海峡大桥的本科论文。然后在1905年，一个更充实的计划几乎被批准，但在最后一刻被砍掉了。我的意思是，如果他们能建造像金门大桥那样美丽的东西，但有50英里长，那将是非常令人惊叹的。我的意思是，1905年杀死这个项目的是什么？嗯，事实证明时机太糟糕了。俄罗斯革命正在开始。所以，你知道，你知道，沙皇尼古拉斯二世有更大的鱼要
fry. And the next thing you know, everybody's caught up in World War One, and then that, you know, bleeds into World War Two, intentions were just high throughout. So the idea kept getting shelved. And then in the 1950s, people started to ramp up and pitch various bridge and tunnel plans again, but none of them panned out. In part because of feasibility concerns, but also of course the cold war. Yeah, yeah. I mean, I could just imagine it being a tough sell because there's the engineering challenge of doing something that massive in any climate and then you think about where
炸。接下来你知道，每个人都被卷入了第一次世界大战，然后那，你知道，蔓延到了第二次世界大战，紧张局势一直很高。所以这个想法一直被搁置。然后在20世纪50年代，人们开始再次增加并推销各种桥梁和隧道计划，但没有一个成功。部分原因是可行性担忧，但也当然是冷战。是的，是的。我的意思是，我能想象它很难推销，因为在任何气候下做如此巨大的事情都有工程挑战，然后你想到他们在哪里
they are in the world and connecting the barren straight. It's super cold. The waters are very turbulent. And there's not a whole lot on either side of these things. You know, directly. Oh, yeah, there's basically nothing, especially at the points that are closest to each other from like these nations. And if they built a bridge, it would probably also have to be closed down for much of the year because it is so cold up there. And if they went the train route, they'd need to figure out how to reconcile these different gauges for each country. And if they
在世界上，连接白令海峡。它超级冷。水域非常湍急。而且这些东西的两边没有太多东西。你知道，直接地。哦，是的，基本上什么都没有，特别是在这些国家彼此最接近的点上。如果他们建造了一座桥，它可能也必须在一年中的大部分时间里关闭，因为它在那里太冷了。如果他们走火车路线，他们需要弄清楚如何协调每个国家的不同轨距。如果他们
went the tunnel route, well, a 50 mile tunnel would be an incredible undertaking and would set a world record. So with all these obstacles and all these really logical reasons why it doesn't exist, is there any realistic prospect of this happening? I mean, I don't know for sure, but I was kind of stunned to find that about a decade ago, the Kremlin approved a rail tunnel proposal. Since 2007, the concept has advanced. In 2008, Vladimir Putin, the then Prime Minister of Russia approved the TKM link. Then in August 2011, the Russian government approved the project. So honestly, it seems like a really cool project, but of course, this ongoing conflict between
走隧道路线，嗯，一条50英里的隧道将是一项令人难以置信的工程，并将创下世界纪录。所以有了所有这些障碍和所有这些非常合乎逻辑的原因，为什么它不存在，这有任何现实的可能性吗？我的意思是，我不知道确定，但我很震惊地发现，大约十年前，克里姆林宫批准了一项铁路隧道提案。自2007年以来，这个概念已经推进。2008年，时任俄罗斯总理弗拉基米尔·普京批准了TKM连接。然后在2011年8月，俄罗斯政府批准了该项目。所以老实说，这看起来是一个非常酷的项目，但当然，这两个国家之间持续的冲突
these two countries makes it really unlikely we're going to see any progress on this project you know, under the current Russian regime anyway. But given how persistent the idea has been to date, I would be shocked if it didn't resurface again someday. I would not be shocked if it resurfaced again. And then when you lay out the fact that this is going to be a decade's long project to actually complete, it's hard to imagine political stability that would persist through the actual construction of such a project.
使得我们真的不太可能看到这个项目的任何进展，你知道，无论如何是在当前的俄罗斯政权下。但考虑到这个想法迄今为止是多么持久，如果它有一天再次浮出水面，我会感到震惊。如果它再次浮出水面，我不会感到震惊。然后当你列出这是一个需要几十年才能真正完成的项目的事实，很难想象政治稳定性会持续到这样一个项目的实际建设过程中。
It really is. It really is. Yeah, getting that handshake to last for decades seems kind of like an impossible task, given the history between our countries. But you're hoping it would be so cool to see it though. It would be amazing. It would be cool. I would drive all the way through Alaska just to get to the bridge.
确实是。确实是。是的，让那种握手持续几十年似乎有点像一项不可能的任务，考虑到我们国家之间的历史。但你希望看到它会很酷。那将是惊人的。那会很酷。我会一路开车穿过阿拉斯加，只是为了到达那座桥。
I love it. Well, thank you, Kurt. This was a great collection of trains again. Yeah. Anytime, Roman. And if you're down for round three, I've got more ideas where these came from. I know you do. It's so good. Thank you, Roman.
我喜欢它。好吧，谢谢你，库尔特。这又是一次很棒的火车收藏。是的。随时，罗曼。如果你支持第三轮，我还有更多的想法，这些想法就是从那里来的。我知道你有。这太好了。谢谢你，罗曼。
Thank you for riding with 99% invisible. 99% invisible was produced this week by Kurt Colestead, Martin Gonzales, and Jacob Moltenado Medina. Chris Baroube was our trustee conductor, music by director of sound, Swan Riao with Mia Burn on guitar and lap steel. Flanie Hall is the senior editor, the rest of the team includes Vivian Leigh, Emmett Fitzgerald, Jason Dalyone, Christopher Johnson, Lashmidon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prone, Sophia Klatsker, and Turn Olivia Green, and me Roman Mars.
感谢您乘坐《99%隐形》。《99%隐形》本周由库尔特·科尔斯泰德、马丁·冈萨雷斯和雅各布·莫尔特纳多·梅迪纳制作。克里斯·巴鲁贝是我们值得信赖的列车员，音乐由声音总监斯旺·里奥创作，米娅·伯恩负责吉他和膝上钢棒吉他。弗兰妮·霍尔是高级编辑，团队的其他成员包括薇薇安·李、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、杰森·戴利恩、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉什米顿、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普罗恩、索菲亚·克拉茨克、特恩·奥利维亚·格林，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。
We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. you can find the show and join discussions about the show on facebook you can tweet at me at roman mars and the show at 99pi org while it lasts you can run instagram reddit and tiktok too you can find links to other stichers shows i love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, I hear the train coming in old 99% She's going into stature at Sir Sexham
我们隶属于Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族，总部现位于北边六个街区外的Pandora大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论，也可以在Twitter上向我@romanmars或向节目组@99piorg发送推文。在这些平台尚存期间，你也可以在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上找到我们。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜爱的其他Stitcher节目链接以及99PI的每一期往期节目。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，我听到火车开进旧的99%，它正驶向Stitcher和Sirius XM]
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
目前本期节目还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。